le burkina faso en son avenir ils sont
treize candidats en lice pour une
élection présidentielle qui s'annonce
crucial dans un pays miné par les
problèmes sécuritaires lié au djihadisme
depuis plusieurs années elle les
burkinabés espère retrouver une paix qui
semble aujourd'hui appartenir au passé
et dans cette optique trois hommes se
détachent particulièrement d'abord le
favori à sa propre succession roch marc
christian kaboré ses supporters
attendent de sa part un coup ko selon
l'expression consacrée à savoir une
victoire nette dès le premier tour
la campagne se passe très bien face à
lui se dresse eddie komboïgo candidat du
parti de l'ancien président blaise
compaore qui a contrôlé le terrain
politique burkinabé pendant 27 ans
jusqu'à une vindicte populaire le
contraignant à fuir le pouvoir et le
pays
en 2014 il ya de cela six ans ça va
manipuler sans venu sur cette place de
la nation pour réclamer le changement du
droit
nous avons perdu le froid par la rue
nous sommes revenus pour conquérir le
pouvoir par les urnes
et zéphirin diabré l'ancien homme clé du
pouvoir lors des différents mandats de
compaoré espère également se qualifier
pour un second tour
son principal argument de campagne la
réconciliation nationale qui doit primer
sur le reste
le burkina faso l'un des pays les plus
pauvres du monde espère aujourd'hui
embrasser un avenir plus serein alors
que ces dernières années les attaques
jihadistes ont causé la fuite de plus
d'un million d'habitants